every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'd be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less I'm Joshua
fields Milburn and I'm riding solo today
although Ryan will be with me for our
next episode we're gonna record an
episode about mental clutter but today I
wanted to talk a little bit about
writing and I get so many questions
about writing whether it's on on social
media or an email or in the writing
class that I teach obviously or of
course with the voicemails that we have
as well a lot of people ask about
writing tips tricks writing success how
to become a full time author things like
that and yeah I don't know where you are
but if you in terms of wanting to write
but I think we are all writers now
whether you write books blog posts
emails tweets or text messages you are a
writer and no matter what your preferred
and medium is what I hope to do today is
share a few tips and and best practices
that I've learned over many years of
writing to help you write more
effectively so this episode is going to
be a little bit different instead of
going through some voicemails and random
questions on social media I'm just going
to sort of summarize a lot of the
questions that I've gotten and and share
some tips with you my first tip for
today when you are trying to improve
your writing and again I don't care
whether it's its business emails or it
is you're trying to write the Great
American Novel or a blog post or
something in between I find that a
rising tide lifts all boats and so my
first step for you is to treat your text
messages like pros so before hitting the
send button look over your text message
check the spelling check the content
check the punctuation of your
message ask yourself what am i
attempting to communicate what am i
attempted to express be more deliberate
with your most common form of casual
writing the text message and you'll
automatically become more deliberate
with your other mediums so when you're
actually sitting down to to write a blog
post or an essay for college or you want
to write a love letter to a loved one if
you've improved your writing in one area
it tends to bleed over into other areas
as well
now those two questions are pretty
important what am i attempting to
communicate one of my attempting to
express now people often ask me why do
you write well I write for two reasons
to communicate and to express myself and
so let's give you a few examples of that
right now I when I think of purely
communicative writing I think of well a
math textbook a calculus textbook right
you you open up a textbook and it is
communicating the subject matter to you
generally in a fairly bland or banal or
even vapid way and and that's fine if
you're just trying to communicate
information but I don't ever think of a
college textbook is something I want to
go and curl up next to a warm fire on
the couch and pull out my calculus
textbook and and begin to recite the the
third chapter that's because it doesn't
express anything it doesn't connect
emotionally so it connects
intellectually but that visceral level
of connection well that comes from
expression and so that's the other
reason why I write I write to express
myself to others and and so I think good
writing tends to marry the two it is
communicative but good writing is also
expressive so the other side of that the
expressive side the extreme example
would be a Torretta person who is on a
subway shouting to absolutely no one at
all maybe you've seen that person before
but the interesting thing about that is
they don't require an audience at all
that that display is going to happen
whether or not you are there in the
first place and
so expressive writing is one thing
communicative writing is another but
when you marry the two you're able to
form you're able to shape interesting
writing that is going to add value to
the reader the second tip I have for you
next step I have is that your words are
your tools and so I think you should
expand your vocabulary if you want to
make your writing more precise now
there's no need to use a ten dollar word
when the ten cent word will suffice but
having more tools in your toolbox will
allow you to select the most appropriate
tool for the job because sometimes you
need an axe and other times you need a
scalpel and so what I've done in the
past is I've picked one new word a day
now and I'll use that word like 21 times
throughout the day and at first it's
very forced you're wedging that new word
into conversation because the first time
you pick up an axe you may not know how
to use it very well but over time after
you've used it repeatedly you get good
at using that tool and the same goes for
the word so I find words a bunch of
different ways you can go to just
dictionary com or you can have the
dictionary app on on your phone I find
that's a great way quite often to get a
a new word although a lot of those words
you'll never find to be applicable and
so the other way that I like to grab new
words is I tend to read books that are
that outside my comfort zone a little
bit a little bit too hard for me at
times and there are often a new
vocabulary words that I learned in there
the nice thing about reading on a Kindle
or an e-reader is you can look up those
words automatically which is pretty nice
because if I look up a word and I said I
really like that word I would like to
try to use it and then what I'll do is
I'll try to wedge it into a conversation
21 times that day and so having a new
word each day general generally I'll
pick at the the the day before and then
I will insert it into my conversations
the next day and at first you're going
to see him
a little bit silly right you're gonna
feel like oh this doesn't fit it's not
me well here's the thing it's not you at
first but at one point you didn't know
any words at all you literally knew zero
words and over time you learned more and
more and more words I find this with
Ella right now
she she's she'll be three pretty soon
and you know she's learning all the time
and we entered a little a code on a door
recently and the locks and unlocks a
door and the right away she goes ooh
that's fancy and I'd never heard heard
her express it that way but also
communicate with with those those same
words those same tools and it's because
it was something she picked up recently
now that sound like it was part of her
everyday vernacular no of course not was
the first time I've ever heard her say
that but over time you know two five
years from now of course if she said
that it might be cute but it would also
sound like it's part of her everyday
usage and so so keep that in mind when
you when you are working with these
tools they will become easier to use
over time and so your words are your
tools find a way to expand your
vocabulary not to sound smart that's not
the point of this in fact that would be
a terrible reason to expand your
vocabulary the reason you want to expand
your vocabulary is to add precision to
your writing and I tend not to write
anything unless I would also speak it as
well and and I think that's a sure sign
of weak writing when you see someone
trying to look smart in their writing
and use these big twenty dollar words
when when they would never the heck they
probably can't even pronounce those
words in real life and yet they're using
those words in text well that just makes
you come off as pompous and so I would
never write a word that I don't use in
my everyday vocabulary my next to my
next tool my my next tip for you is to
do it daily to write daily I think if
you want to improve your writing you
should write every day make writing a
daily habit
I look at writing as a muscle and if you
don't use it you will lose it and for me
the the best way to guarantee consistent
writing was was twofold first off I was
told these four words the the four words
that really changed my habits my writing
habit sit in the chair
sit in the chair a writer named Donald
Pollock said this and it really stuck
with me because I realized that writing
is this weird craft that we expect to
learn via osmosis somehow that I want to
be a writer I am an aspiring writer and
therefore I am going to be a writer
without actually doing the craft the
strange thing is I don't see this in
many other creative fields or any other
creative fields that I could think about
when when you see a carpenter he's not
an aspiring carpenter he either is a
carpenter or he or she is a carpenter or
he or she is not a carpenter right and
and the same goes for most other
professions what makes you a carpenter
is that you are into carpentry you do
the work and for a writer that means
sitting in the chair uninterrupted doing
the work every day now for me
I first became enthralled with writing
in my early 20s I was actually a very
late to the game I didn't like reading
as a child and and then I discovered
literature in my early 20s originally
through some sort of vapid popcorn
fiction and genre paperbacks from the
airport kind of thing but in time I
discovered literary fiction through the
works of people like Bret Easton Ellis
and David Foster Wallace and Mary Carr
who writes some incredible memoirs and
and some other folks as well and I found
this amazing exchange of consciousness
that was going on between the author
the reader and it didn't require a
direct interaction in fact the author
may have been dead for fifty years
I could still have this exchange of
consciousness I could see what was going
on inside that authors head and that
made me want to write because it made me
want to
it gave me an avenue to express myself
in a different way that didn't seem
possible before and I don't see any
other creative medium that really
communicates and expresses as profoundly
as writing I think music often comes
close I don't think that it does exactly
the same way in fact it can it can do
things that writing can't for sure but
writing was this exchange of
consciousness that I had never really
experienced before and that started with
literature for me but then other kinds
of writing whether it was nonfiction or
prose poetry or or a bunch of other
types of writing I learned that you
could communicate with someone in a way
that really resonated with them
viscerally it resonated with him on
emotional level because you're also able
to express yourself and that's what made
the writing stick for me not the rote
memorization of a calculus textbook but
the communicative nature of expressive
communication and so I I decided that
sitting in the chair after hearing
Donald ray Pollock who has written a
couple amazing books the devil all the
time is a novel he wrote which is
amazing and a short story collection
called knock'em stiff which is an actual
town in Ohio near Chillicothe Ohio he
and then he grew up there and it's kind
of a ghost town now actually but it's
called Malcolm stuff and there's a good
backstory there and if you want to read
the book you can check it out
Sean if you can put in the show notes
that'd be great
but he said sit in the chair with no
distractions so no cellphone no Wi-Fi no
internet none of this stuff that's going
to get in your way I don't have the TV
on in the background because here's the
thing when I was an aspiring writer
throughout most of my 20s what did that
mean well it meant I aspired a lot but I
didn't actually accomplish much but I
didn't get much done because I set up
too many rules for myself early on when
I was aspiring to write I'd say yeah I
will write I just have to have
everything perfect I have to have my my
writing program set up just right and
like a Peter needs to be fully charged
and I have to have my pen and my pad
next to me and I gotta make my cup of
coffee and I need you know what I forgot
to put the laundry in the dryer I've got
to go do that and so I make up these 15
rules that of course would always
prevent me from getting the work done
they'd prevent me from sitting in the
chair because if you set up enough sort
of draconian rules to get started you'll
never get started there's always going
to be something that gets in the way and
so the way that I was able to start
sitting in the chair those four profound
words is I was able to remove as many
rules as possible for me that meant
getting up a little bit earlier I
already enjoyed getting up early now I
like to get over around 3:30 and that's
naturally whenever I can but I'll tell
you this I remove the rules my only rule
for writing now is that I have to get
out of bed that's the rule you have to
and so as soon as I wake up I don't
lollygag you know I know I don't stick
in bed and pull the covers over my head
I wake up and I will get up and I will
start writing and and that is what's
important to me that's the only rule
that I need to be successful now if I
could figure out how to eliminate that
rule and write in my sleep then yeah
maybe if you have some tips let me know
on Twitter I'm at jfm there I'd love to
know how you write in your sleep
although I do keep a notepad by my bed
so I have to wake up to actually write
that down though although sometimes I'm
half asleep and I write it down because
I'll wake up in the middle of the night
and I'll have this notepad and I'll
write down the most profound thing and
then when I wake up in the morning is
just jabber ish I think what the hell
was I thinking last night now
occasionally there will be a nugget or
two in there so I find it to be
important it's not a total waste but for
every nugget there is a giant heap of
dung that I have to go sifting through
generally and so sit in the chair what
was really important to me eliminating
those rules was was really important to
me and I like to write about three hours
a day every day now
and I find that to be important to to
for consistency and when I started
though I didn't have those three hours a
day I was working 80 hours a week in the
corporate world now I can't tack on
another 21 hours on top of that there
are only a hundred and sixty-eight hours
in a week and we need how many of those
to sleep and so we have what a 100 to
120 waking hours depending on well
hopefully you're sleeping enough
hopefully you're sleeping 7 8 9 hours a
night but we just talked about that in
the last episode the health episode so
so you know I realized that I needed to
do something and especially to get some
momentum because I had no inertia I was
an aspiring writer but I wasn't writing
I needed to do something I needed to sit
in the chair I needed to do it every day
that's this tip do it every day well you
know what I got up an hour early so
instead of getting up at 5:45 every
morning I would get up at 4:40 for every
morning I have my alarm set for 444 I'd
roll out of bed I'd start writing and
that's how I would start my days and boy
did I feel productive because by at 5:45
when my second alarm went off I knew I
was done writing I had already
accomplished so much so I didn't worry
about word count or page count I know
that helps some people so if that helps
you great for me what I worried about
was hour count how long was I sitting in
the chair undistracted not allowing
myself to be interrupted by tweets or
Facebook or whatever and the reason I
recommend three hours to too many people
now is it takes about 22 minutes on
average for a creative person to get
into flow state now yours could be
totally different and maybe 15 minutes
for you it might be 45 minutes for you
to get into that flow state I don't know
where you are but I find that to be
about true for me it's it's around the
20 minute mark but if I allow a tweet to
creep in and I'm all of a sudden
responding to Twitter for 3 to 5 minutes
I've interrupted that flow state so
let's say I do that twice in an hour
well I'm actually never going to get
into a flow state in that hour if I'm
interrupted every 20 minutes and it
takes me 22 minutes to get into that
state and so being uninterrupted is
really important because if I spin the
first 20 to 30 minutes just really
getting into that
State well everything after that is
gravy and so spending the additional
hour two hours or three hours in the
chair
allows me to be far more creative in the
long run without without a lot without a
lot of breaks or a lot of interruptions
and I find that to be to be important I
also find it important to plan a stop at
some point because you don't want to
burn yourself out and so so if you have
a three-hour break you can stop
mid-sentence in fact if you stop
mid-sentence that often leaves you
somewhere creative to start the next day
and so you can pick up the work right
away the other way I have found to make
my writing more consistent holding
myself accountable is to start a blog in
fact I would tell you that the the best
creative decision I've ever made or
maybe I'll call it a professional
decision although it wasn't initially a
a professional decision was to start a
blog and I didn't really know it at the
time that it would completely change my
life but when Ryan came to me with the
idea of you know we should communicate
this nonfiction story see I was
completely ignorant to the whole
nonfiction genre in terms of writing the
only non-fiction writing I had done
prior to starting the minimalists was
some vapid corporate emails and even
those I tried to make a little bit more
fun and creative because otherwise if
they're just communicative I'm not
expressing myself and that doesn't seem
very interesting to me and it's gonna be
harder to get people's buy-in and so I
would write business emails but that was
the extent of my nonfiction endeavor in
terms of writing but I found that
starting a blog in fact Ryan and I
didn't even know it was called a blog
when we first started it we called a
website and we didn't know what a blog
or a blog post was a blog post was was
well I thought a blog was where 83 year
old women catalog pictures of their cats
and it turns out those are just the
really popular blogs and so we started a
website and we started writing essays
because that's what we were familiar
with you'd read essays in The New Yorker
or the Atlantic or something like that
and so we write started writing these
short essays about our lives about our
separate journeys into minimalism and
about our experience growing and
and our trials and tribulations our
failures our successes our experiments
and we changed over time and what was
really interesting about that is I found
out that I was writing fiction for the
better part of a decade because I didn't
have a very interesting life to write
about in the first place but when I
started making some fundamental changes
in my life my life started becoming more
interesting it became noteworthy
literally noteworthy as in taking down
notes and then writing about those
experiences and so people often ask how
do I know what to write about well you
can write fiction and you can write
about whatever you want I think it was
David Foster Wallace who who said that
writing fiction is creating from
complete silence and writing nonfiction
is creating from absolute noise and so
they are radically different you you're
starting with functionally nothing on
the side of fiction you can make
whatever you want to make you can make
fairies who ride spaceships and they're
fighting off um you know unicorns that
whatever you want to make you can you
can make with with nonfiction you're
trying to tweeze out the truly
interesting elements of what's going on
around you and making it palatable to to
the reader and so starting a blog had
allowed me to develop that habit and
also develop that skill in front of an
audience get a lot of feedback from
people now we certainly didn't have a
readership at first definitely not five
million people in fact the the first
month we figure out how to track traffic
52 people visited our website and I know
that doesn't sound impressive to many
people but the truth is that I was
really excited that 52 people were
showing up and finding value in what we
were writing because truth be told I
spend the better part of a decade just
writing fiction and the only people who
read my stuff was well the only people
who read it really were agents who said
no or publishers who said no basically
people who told me no wasn't very good
and I thought they were crazy but
unbeknownst to me a lot of it actually
was bad it took getting the bad stuff
out there what and Lamont calls the the
shitty first draft did it getting the
words onto the page was really important
so that it's it's practicing basically
and and I liken it to to a jam session
basically I got this from our our
fearless producer Sean Harding here he's
also an amazing editor and writer and he
he talked to me about this this metaphor
of jam session right and you get a band
together in a room and they just start
jamming it's not meant for tape it's not
meant to be recorded your first draft of
something often needs to be just that it
needs to be a jam session no one's it's
not meant to be read it's not meant to
be scrutinized like some sort of college
assignment right it is meant to just get
the words onto the page you'll actually
hear people say that it is a stream of
consciousness writing I don't
necessarily believe in a stream of
consciousness the same way I think I
think language is comes after
consciousness so we can get into that
into some other podcasts but but anyway
I prefer to look at it as a jam session
when I'm getting the words onto the page
so I spend about well what we'll talk
about that in a minute it's a future tip
but I spend most of my time actually
rewriting good writing is is rewriting
and the best way for me to start
improving my writing growing in my
writing was to start a blog and we'll
throw in and the show notes Ryan and I
wrote an essay called how to start a
successful blog today and we write about
the sort of 15 reasons you should blog
20 reasons you shouldn't blog and then
also probably just as important the the
step by step process we went to to to
set up our blog it was relatively easy
and I tell you I didn't know anything
about starting a blog when we first
started I couldn't even spell HTML let
alone set up a blog but we we figured
out how to use WordPress and install
some themes really easily and so setting
up a blog was wait
easier than I thought and the only thing
I wish I would have done was start it
much earlier so if you want to see our
recipe we'll throw that in the show
notes or you can just go to the
minimalists dot-com a slash blog and
read that essay it's a fairly long one
but it is a step by step recipe how to
start a sec a successful blog today my
next tip for you is a basic one but it
is important punctuation is pace so to
add variety velocity and cadence to your
writing I encourage you to play around
with with different punctuation periods
commas in dashes colons semicolons short
sentences communicate tension longer
run-on sentences on the other hand help
establish a frantic hurried rhythm a
feeling that the pace is picking up as
the words tumble onto the page and so I
find that by adding a variety to the
sentences or how we're communicating the
best way to do that is with punctuation
that is going to communicate to the
reader where we are in the brain of the
character or the author or the the brain
voice of the the writing the narrator
whatever it may be the just the business
email if you want to write something
that communicates tension you're gonna
have short choppy punchy sentences right
Bam Bam Bam Bam
and if you want to maybe communicate
chaos you're gonna have longer run on
ish sentences that the tumble onto the
page and so find the right punctuation
again going back to my very first tip
the best way to play around with that to
get good at it is do it and your text
messages play around with the
punctuation in your text messages to try
to communicate in these little short
bursts and you'll be more effective in
your longer writing as well my next tip
for you is to avoid throat clearing
blogs books and social media blog posts
or social media posts rather are
littered with I think unnecessary intros
solipsistic digressions and avoidable
drivel
I say ditch the nonsense and state your
points when in doubt I find that it's
best that I delete my first two
paragraphs in a blog post and see if the
writing improves too often I I see this
when I am reading a blog or someone
sends me a link to a blog post or an
article somewhere and it's a sure sign
of amateur writing someone is throat
clearing at the very beginning of a blog
post what they want to say I'm sorry I
haven't written in a while well no one
really cares and half the people arena
don't even know you haven't written in a
while why why would you begin with an
apology unless it's a unless it's you
know ironic or something and there are
ways that you could do it but but an
apology like that it's just a little bit
of throat clearing and that's silly get
to your point and I find one of the ways
to do that delete the first two
paragraphs does it make my writing
better and often the answer is yes
delete delete delete delete delete
why delete so much well that's my next
tip don't waste the reader's time our
time and attention are two of our most
precious resources so it is selfish to
force the reader to spend 15 minutes
reading something that could have and
should have been communicated in 90
seconds so if you want to earn your
readers trust don't waste his or her
time I mean come on let's think about
this we we are on social media and so we
said well it's free for them to read
it's free for them to follow me it's
free for them to read my blog it's free
for them to subscribe to my email yeah
it's free monetarily but that's a very
narrow way to look at it it's not free
for them to read your blog you're asking
for their most precious resources you're
asking for their time and their
attention
what's more precious than that money is
a renewable resource you can't renew
your time once you've given it up you've
given it up and so I don't want to waste
my readers time in fact that's why you
look at our you may look at our blog
posts what I would call an essay and
generally they are well they start out
at about 2,500 words quite often
and then I will narrow it down to 700
words 500 words 400 words sometimes I'll
copy or cut a paragraph from the entire
2,500 word blog post and say you know
what these two paragraphs alone are
truly communicating what I want to
communicate and so I give my readers
credit I know that they're smarter than
we pretend they are we pretend a lot of
people need to have everything dumbed
down to them that's silly
readers are smarter than you think and
so you don't have to show them the
entire iceberg if you show them the tip
of the iceberg they know that it is an
iceberg don't waste their time spending
2500 words
communicating is something that can be
communicated in a sentence or two and
that good that goes for social media and
everything else and so when I when I
Whittle it down to 500 words Shan Mei
Mei you know get out his scalpel and cut
another hundred words from it and and
just make it a little bit tidier and so
having someone else to help keep you
accountable is also really important
having someone who you can share your
writing with whether that's online or a
close friend family member it doesn't
need to be a person who's a writing
expert in fact some of the best writing
advice I've gotten or just from friends
they may not they may not be able to
give me the the grammatical or
syntactical tips that Shawn can give me
but other people can say you know what
that really resonated with me and here's
the part that I loved and that's
especially proven true with with a lot
of the books that we've written so Ryan
and I have written three books together
I also published a novel when I was age
30 so Ryan and I wrote a book called
minimalism with a meaningful life a
fairly short book I think it's maybe 120
hundred and 30 pages long in its final
form the first draft of that was 300
pages and we we realize it was called
minimalism a 300 page book about
minimalism wait we can taste the irony
here and we wrote about that in the the
intro of the new edition of the book
because we basically deleted the whole
thing and started over and said we can
communicate this differently and and
found a way to delete a lot of it and
same goes for other books
everything that remains which is my
favorite book of ours was over 700 pages
I think it was it was about 750 pages
and it's bloated Zenith and what we
realized is that you know what we really
want to get this down to something that
is palatable now these weren't 750
publishable pages don't don't mistake me
here and say we were going to publish
750 page book that was never the intent
but it took creating a lot to be able to
will it down to something that was truly
meaningful now it's about 200 pages and
it's in its final state we also have an
essay collection called essential which
we put out a new edition of last year
and 2015 and man Shawn that was what
seven hundred eight hundred pages when
we were going through it and and it's
about three hundred pages now and the
reason it was it was so bloated at first
as we were we knew we had to put
everything in there all of the best of
the minimalist it's an essay collection
and so now I has about 150 essays in it
but it originally had about 340 350
essays in it and we we whittled it down
and and we kept arguing and fighting and
and saying I really want this all know
it's communicated there and I think it's
better communicated like this and
eventually we got it down to something
that was palatable same with as a decade
fades although that's a little bit
different that's a novel I published
when I was 30 and I actually spent most
of my 20s writing that novel mid and
late 20s I should say and so a lot of
the writing in there is a good
representation of my 25 year old self I
spent about a thousand pages on that
book to get it down to it's 250 page
state now and I think what's important
there is I put a lot of work into it and
I was willing to who is a Fitzgerald
kill your darlings Faulkner yeah that's
right so its Faulkner the kill your
darlings what I would say is make the
page bleed and so I will often bring out
that red pen and and and just get down
to deleting deleting deleting and and I
think that's that's gonna be really
important in fact it'll it'll be
important for an upcoming tip
here all right so my next tip is 30
percent composition 70 percent editing
so for every hour you spend writing I
recommend spending 3 hours editing
shaping your work into something more
concise more powerful more beautiful
writing
well good writing at least is rewriting
and so keep that in mind
as I went through those other books and
said ok as a decade fades was a thousand
pages again not a thousand publishable
pages it was getting that shitty first
draft onto the pages the second draft
being slightly better moving things
around in fact with that book the main
character was originally a different
main character and that didn't come
around so at the very end I think I was
27 28 years old when I when I sort of
found that main character it was a
totally different character was written
from a a different perspective a
first-person perspective instead of a
third-person perspective it was also
originally written in a present tense
and instead of a past tense and so I was
able to adjust those things through
various drafts but the important thing
was not to find the perfect tense and
the perfect perspective and and and the
perfect characters and have everything
be perfect because if your affinity for
perfection is high you'll never actually
put the words on the page realize that
once you put the words on the page
you're just you're heaping this pile of
rock together right now and and the
metaphor I like to use when you think of
Michelangelo sculpting the Statue of
David he didn't start with the Statue of
David he started with this huge chunk of
marble and he had to start cutting away
and and the difference with writing is
we also have to create the marble from
which we sculpt and so that first draft
of of words that no one's going to read
I actually call it a zero draft when I'm
going through it just getting the words
onto the page that zero draft is
important because it gives us the marble
from which we're going to sculpt our a
version of David and even if that's of a
business email or a text message you can
have a shitty first draft in your text
message I know when I'm texting people
and and that those little little bubble
comes up and they see that I'm
plying to them they have to be like why
is he taking so long to respond to me
because I'm trying to craft a message to
them that honors them with brevity it
honors them with clarity and I often
fail at that but I do my best to be both
expressive and communicative even even
in that sense and so creating that huge
huge pile of marble is important that
that chunk of marble is important so
that first 30% of my time I spend
writing and so you could say for every
one day that I'm spending writing I'm
gonna spend three days editing I'm gonna
pour the words onto the page now for you
that might be slightly different you
might say I'm gonna spend two days
writing and four days editing you know
it's really up to you to determine
what's right for you but don't
underestimate the the editing and the
way that I do that is during the
composition process the jam session
writing I'll give you a few tips here
but but the jam session writing I make
sure I treat that as junk it is truly a
jam session just getting it out there I
know that it's not being recorded I know
I can mess up there can be spelling
errors there could be some tactical
errors there can be grammatical errors
there can be errors and tints there can
be errors and accuracy there can be all
of these errors it's just about getting
it onto the page getting it out of you
so you have something to work with later
and once I once I get it now here's the
thing often people get that they get so
caught up because we've trained
ourselves to be our own self editors in
the moment and and that will kill your
writing if you're constantly self
editing that jam session and so what I
tell my students my writing students is
that you know what you're going to have
to find a way during composition to
always stave off the self editor that is
so important don't allow yourself to
edit your own work as you're writing it
that will come during the editing
process and you'll learn to enjoy
both sides of the process the
composition and the editing side of
things and so if you're not able to
stave off the self editor at first and I
know that's really difficult I've when
Ryan took my writing class that was the
thing he found most difficult and a lot
of my students find that difficult to is
all I just wrote that sentence let me go
back and change them let me change this
let me change that let me change that so
if you're having trouble staving off the
self editor here a couple tips for you
you can either get high-tech with it
pseudo high-tech I guess whatever
writing program you're using I use one
called Scrivener but whatever writing
program you're using you can turn your
text to white so white text onto white
background and therefore you can't see
what you're writing and you're just
dumping those words out punctuation
errors spelling errors and all just
getting it out there or you can get low
tech you can just tape a piece of paper
over the screen and just keep writing
keep keep writing spin those hours in
the chair and let it pour onto the page
you'll be able to edit it later and it
will be frustrating it'll be difficult
at first but it'll be so worth it now
many of my students that they they have
trouble with this and so one of the
things that one of the analogies I'll
have them do is take a piece of paper
out and so if you want to try this with
me you're welcome to do it I'll do it
right now take a piece of paper out and
I'm in one second I'm gonna have you
write your name okay and you're gonna
write your full name how you normally
would write your name if you're signing
a check or you're just writing it down
on a piece of paper you can print you
can sign it you can do whatever you want
however you would typically write your
name on a piece of paper with a pin all
right on three we're gonna do it
together one two three all right done
put your pencils down
it took me less than four seconds to do
about three and a half seconds to write
my name okay now here's what we do the
same thing we write half of your name
but we're just gonna do every other
letter okay
and so with me that'll be like I don't
know J and then s and then we'll just
keep going down the line until we get to
the very end of our name same exact way
you would have written it but skip every
letter so it would be half the time
right ready one two three go
still going oh I messed up
that's alright keep going oh alright
well is that like 14 seconds I think
that well that doesn't make any sense
right well why does it take three or
four times as long for me to write my
name when it's half of sure what's
because we're not used to it right so
you're not gonna be used to composition
this way but it's gonna make you better
because here's the thing if you're to
keep right if you were to keep writing
every other letter and you did it every
single day over the course of two months
three months a year you're going to cut
down your your the time it takes to
write your name by 40% 50% and and
that's what's important you're actually
going to improve even though it's more
difficult at first and and that's what
is important to understand here by by
changing your pattern you're going to
change the way that you create
meaningful writing for other people and
so be willing to get stuck in the
composition and then move over to the
the editing portion on a different day
returning to the text that you composed
and making it into something shaping it
into something more concise something
more powerful something more beautiful
because good writing is truly it's just
rewriting my next tip for you is
something I call a narrative urgency
what is narrative urgency well I think
that every sentence that you're writing
should serve a purpose your first
sentence must make your reader want to
read the second sentence now the second
sense a little bit different the second
sentence must make your reader want to
read the third sentence right so forth
and so on that goes for a business email
that goes for a blog post that goes for
a facebook status update and that
certainly goes for a novel one of my
favorite pastimes I'll go to a bookstore
and I'll just start reading the first
sentences I love going to a bookstore
crack
as a random book and reading that first
sentence does it draw me in why do I
call that narrative urgency well does it
create urgency does it make me want to
read the next sentence if so I keep
reading if not I stop in fact common
practice of mine is if a book but I
don't get past page fifty in a book
usually unless it's a masterpiece
it's because I don't want to waste my
time finishing a book just for the sake
of finishing now I realize that some
books get really good after page 180
they're American Psycho is a really
great example of that
I remember just sort of drudging through
it and it was you know a phenomenal book
for me in my early 20s it made me
realize you could do satire in a way
that didn't seem like conventional
satire but but anyway for the most part
I do not make it past page 50 unless
there is something really special going
on because every sentence needs a serve
of the neck so when we talked earlier
about I'll kill your darlings let's make
it a little more graphic kill your
babies these are things that you've
created you've birthed these words onto
the page but guess what don't get too
tied to it be willing to let go of
everything I know I know how beautiful
that sentence is that you that you
crafted I realize how madly in love you
are without alliteration that clever
twist of phrase that really cool
punctuation that that line that
character said that's all great but if
it doesn't serve a purpose in the
narrative you have to be willing to let
it go I know that's hard and so the
leading is important and you can create
a new a new draft if you want and that
way you have your zero draft that's just
sitting there elsewhere and you you
still have that composition should you
choose you want to go back to it you
could recess or to resuscitate your
babies I suppose but you know what
having that zero draft there as a backup
is fine then it'll allow you to delete
delete delete delete and then keep
deleting until you've gotten down to the
most urgent thing that is going to allow
your first sentence to take the reader
to the second sins it's going to propel
them to the third
and it's going to propel them all the
way to the end of your blog posts all
the way to the end of your novel your
memoir your nonfiction book your tweet
your email whatever it may be it's going
to get the reader to the end of that in
a way where they stay interested they
stay emotionally and intellectually
engaged that narrative urgency will
allow them to do that
my next step for you is to avoid too
many adverbs this is a sure sign of
amateur writing the overuse of adverbs
especially ly adverbs a woman in a story
isn't incredibly pretty she's beautiful
the sky isn't very blue it's as your
find the right words and that will allow
you to avoid using adverbs as crutches
and I think the reason that we do this
in writing so often is that it's how we
we do in our everyday vernacular we'll
say it's incredibly difficult it's just
difficult right you don't have to say
it's extremely this or incredibly that
or whatever avoiding these adverbs will
make your writing tighter and more
precise and and so again the best way to
do that as you find any ly adverb in
your writing delete it and then reread
the sentence aloud that's really
important in fact in in Missoula and
back in Dayton Ohio I'm often known as
the guy who looks somewhat schizophrenic
because I write aloud when I'm walking
to try to get pace and Anand diction
down appropriately and so you have all
of these you have tone you have timbre
you your writing takes a shape that your
author's voice takes a shape and so
reading it aloud is really important and
then delete and reread the thing aloud
and does that make the writing more
powerful often yes in fact yes for a few
reasons one is because you've eliminated
the excess and as a metal minimalism is
about and oh by the way the other
adverbs that stay in because they really
do make sense
to be there they're more powerful they
now hold more weight and that makes your
writing better my next tip for you is
follow the rules and then unfollow the
rules you should learn the rules so you
can break them effectively so I'm gonna
recommend a couple books at the end of
this the the podcast here because I
think it's important to not get too tied
up in the rules but know what the rules
are so you that you can you can break
them because otherwise your writing is
going to look haphazard your your
composition will will feel stilted
because you don't know what rules you're
breaking and which rules you are not and
if you are breaking the rules you're not
going to know why you're doing it and so
understanding what what the rules of
basic grammar are sentence structure etc
that's all that's all great but then you
can learn how to split infinitives and
you can learn how to have run-on
sentences you can learn how to have
sentence fragments these things work
very effectively in certain contexts as
long as you know why you're using them
and so you can learn about more advanced
grammatical rules as well or tactics
like polysyndeton or a cinder ton which
i won't i won't go into detail with
right now but it's these little these
little tools that will help you improve
your writing and a little bit more
precision and more brevity but also add
more more life to your writing by by
being willing to change those rules over
time my last tip for you is to read more
about writing now I don't like writing
about writing I think writing about
writing is like kissing your beautiful
sister Oh know what what I what I do
want to do though is I want to improve
my writing I really enjoy writing I very
rarely write about writing in fact
talking about writing this will likely
be the only writing podcast that I do
but you should
learn more about writing and part of
that has to do with reading about
writing so a couple tips for you here
whether it's reading grammar books or
different things like that but also you
can find a bunch of articles online if
you I have a how to write better
Facebook page and how to write better
Twitter feed it's all free stuff but we
tweet out tips and articles about about
writing and grammar and usage and the
the origin of words and we just a bunch
of writing tips basically and so you can
find this facebook.com slash to write
better that's T ough write better and
the same on Twitter at to write better
you can find the e how to write better
there but find ways to improve your
writing whether that's with with
articles with books etc I would
definitely encourage you to do that you
can also take a writing class you can
get with other people who are writers
and and find ways to to help them and
also have them help you read each
other's work
offer comments positive criticism it's
still criticism you're helping them
improve but in a way that isn't meant to
to be simply negative criticism it's a
critique of the work to help them grow
and allows you to contribute as well so
sort of a mutual benefit there all right
and I'd love to hear what you have to
say about writing what writing tips do
you have do you have other tips for us
as well you can leave us a voicemail at
4:06 two one nine seven eight three nine
will air some of our favorite comments
and tips on the next episode and now I'd
like to move on to real quick our added
value a portion of the show and this is
where we recommend something that has
added value to our lives and this is
because I'm talking about writing right
now the the two books that in my writing
class I asked students to read there is
a book the required reading is a book
called grammatically correct and it's by
a woman named and Stillman and man she
just does an awesome job not being too
prescriptive with her book and she makes
it interesting enough it's expressive
enough but
communicates plenty of the rules and if
you're like me at first it'll drive you
crazy because she isn't very
prescriptive and I want a prescription
here is the definitive rule well let's
think about that for a minute language
has invented by humans and changes
dramatically over time
Shakespeare was supposedly modern
English and it is radically different
from how we write and talk and
communicate today and so language is
fluid it is ever-changing and so she
presents a great snapshot a picture of
the best standard written English but
also allows for deviations from that and
so grammatically correct we'll put a
link to that in the show notes and the
other book is gardeners modern usage
dictionary now it's not a traditional
dictionary where you look up words but
it is a usage dictionary and a Brian
Gardner is a grammarian and a
lexicographer and he does a phenomenal
job also not being too prescriptive but
but providing us with turns of phrases
and rules very specific rules around
usage it's a very big book if you were
to throw it down and your doorstop is
gonna sound like a bomb goes off but it
is a very useful reference and so I keep
those two books fairly close to me
they're on my bookshelf they're often
referenced because they help me be a
better writer especially when I'm
thinking about a rule is it different
than or different from or different - oh
yeah that's right it's different from
unless you're in Great Britain or
Australia different - works there as
well but in everyday vernacular we may
say different than this cup is different
than that cup but that's not correct in
good writing and so you'll be able to
figure out those little usage quirks and
many many many of them as a reference
guide in Gardner's book I think he does
a phenomenal job it's the best usage
dictionary that I've ever seen all right
real quick I'd love to move on to right
here right now this is some news updates
from the minimalists as you probably
know we have a film coming out
minimalism a documentary about the
important things Ryan and I are
hitting the road in about a week
actually wow this is this is awesome
we're going to more than a dozen cities
and most of them are sold out but we
still have some tickets left in Boston
and Miami and Dallas and Seattle
although by the time this post I don't
know whether or not they'll still be
tickets in all of those cities but if
your city sold out or if we are not
coming to your city don't worry the film
premieres May 24 2016 in a whole bunch
of cities 400 cities across the United
States
now this isn't like a traditional
release this is a limited release
meaning in those 400 cities it will play
for one night only in most of those
cities so the only way to ensure that it
will play in your city will actually
screen in your city is if you get your
if you reserve your tickets in advance
so just go to minimalism film.com you
can see the trailer there and you can
just click on see the film find the
theater closest to you next week we have
our final Tuesday's with the minimalists
Ryan and I have really been enjoying
this but right before we go on the road
we're gonna have our final episode of
tuesdays with the minimalists on
periscope and Twitter so if you've been
enjoying that join us for one last
episode on Twitter and periscope we're
at the minimalists on on both platforms
speaking of being on tour you can still
follow us on Twitter and periscope and
Instagram and Facebook we're gonna share
a bunch of updates from the road a bunch
of photos behind the scenes live video
and QA while we're on the road so tune
in for all of that fun stuff and if
you're interested in a writing class I
teach a four-week writing class called
how to write better also a one-day
writing workshop you can find both of
those at how to write better org and
finally if you want to connect with open
minded like-minded people in your area
you can go to minimalist org and there
are a hundred free local meetup groups
in 8 different countries and if there
isn't a meetup group close to you don't
worry we have a meetup group with an
online city and and you can meet with
the thousands of people who meet there
all the time they share articles
they post status updates they hold each
other accountable they contribute to
each other and they talk about
everything from careers and
relationships to decluttering and
Finance and everything in between
finally here are some voicemail comments
from our listeners from some previous
episodes hi my name is Samantha
I'm calling from Columbus Ohio and I've
been really enjoying this podcast this
message is in response to episode 14 and
I have a comment for the question from
caller regional about how to stay
minimalist while in college and a system
that I developed to minimize the number
of notebooks I was carrying around
because this can get confusing if you're
if you have a lot of papers in different
classes or if you have a lot of
materials files that your professors
expect you to read my best system is I
would have a laptop I would type all my
notes while my professor is talking in
the lecture and this way because I type
faster than I write I'm able to get more
comprehensive notes that's almost
conversational as I'm reading them back
and helps me remember a lot easier and
after this I also had a Kindle which I'd
really recommend or if you prefer a
tablet I found that the Kindles are
easier on my eyes for long greetings and
you can also highlight within the Kindle
and take notes inside of it so after I
took my notes on a document I would
email them to my Kindle account and I
would do the same thing with the PDF
files that my professors wanted me to
read because often I had a lot of papers
to supplement my textbook so I would
send the documents to my Kindle and then
I can carry all of my notes for all of
my classes on my Kindle it fits in my
pocket if it's in my purse look and whip
it out read and study anytime and I
found I was more likely to go back and
review my notes because it was easy to
read on the Kindle I could take them
with me and it just made studying a lot
easier but I didn't have to carry around
so much I wanted to leave a comment for
the minimalist as something that I found
has
a lot of value to my life especially
after I completed the packing party that
I did in my room so I've started my
journey of becoming a minimalist myself
and after telling a lot of my friends
about this one of my co-workers
suggested this website we have in
Toronto which is called bunts and it is
a trading zone for people who live in
Toronto at first I was a little bit
apprehensive because as a minimalist I
don't want to be taking on more stuff
but what's great about the site is you
can trade for anything you can paid for
food subway tokens if you need a new
camera if you're looking for a sexual
oils you're looking for handy down low
literally whatever it is you're looking
for you can find it on this website and
it is absolutely amazing I haven't spent
any money for the past two months I
haven't spent my last two paychecks
because I've been getting on my food on
buns I beginning on my switch opens on
buns I found no I got a typewriter which
is amazing because I've always always
wanted a typewriter so it's just I think
something that is a really cool system
and we have in Toronto and I finding
that some other cities are starting to
catch on even one of my friends started
their own buns in Montreal so it's just
kind of a neat idea I know even on
Kijiji there is a trading option and I
just think that that's kind of a cool
way if you're not necessarily looking
for money you're looking for a
particular item that really adds value
to your life and this is something that
I found is super duper cool hi this is
sherry from st. Louis this is a comment
in regard to a question that somebody
had on the career podcast episode about
getting a second phone for work and I
just wanted to say that if that person
doesn't actually want to have a physical
second phone I would suggest getting a
Google Voice number which is free they
can set it up so that it calls their
cell phone but you can also set up
things like Do Not Disturb for certain
hours or schedule after hours so that
it doesn't ring when you're at home so
instead of having you know to physical
phones they can just manage two
different phone numbers it's a little
bit different than having a sim card
that you switch out but they will have
to check with their phone plan and their
service to see if that would work with
Google Voice if there's any other
overages like data and things like that
all right Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists you can give us a call
406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes or to your
you
you